[Music]
the season finale of Game of Thrones
aired Sunday you check that out great
day as usual on this series a lot of
characters were killed
did you watch handy to check it out I
did and and now I'm a little confused as
to who has the rightful claim to the
Iron Throne at this point yeah that's
right it got a little confusing Tommen
didn't have children and there are no
other male heirs left so I think Cersei
took it over yeah yeah just took over
well I mean there might be a male heir
out there they just might not have found
them yet what is it Andy it's to me it
says greetings I'm pleased to inform you
Andrew firstborn from the house of
Richter that you are the rightful heir
to the Iron Throne
[Applause]
Wow that's great news yeah I can't pull
up another wave another on look at that
Raven oh I'm [ __ ] real yeah it says
to claim the throne please wire fifty
thousand gold coins to the iron bank of
Nigeria via Western Union it's got a
bank routing number that's easy enough
Andy Andy I'm okay I'm sorry this is
starting to sound a little weird to me a
little suspicious look can't you just be
happy that something good is happening
to me for once
I'm sorry written smaller they could
have put it on one part that's alright
Andy let's not we'll need your social
security number to verify the
transaction please email it to king of
westeros at not scam dot bill Andy Andy
that's clearly not a legitimate email
address it's a scam yeah I guess you're
right
I still do wonder where all these Ravens
are coming from though what what do you
mean he said no did you rule the Seven
Kingdoms scam but that's why I would not
scam in the email
what oh we didn't want the penis
enlargement pills either more for me I
guess
cheater sex party
[Applause]
back of the birthday
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now just keeps showing those shitty
birds please Kathy thank you very much
you think to be enlisted in that Turkey
sitting right there the puppeteer okay
what a rat there opera a goth kids
birthday party okay guys
you